foreign
to
beliefs
because
what I realized
pretty quickly when I stumbled across
your words Kapil is that I had a whole
lot of beliefs about the world and I
pretended as though
those were the truth because they felt
so real to me
my beliefs must be true right otherwise
why would I have them as
a belief and over the last couple years
I've gotten really good at letting go
of bully setting them down is probably a
way to talk about it
but I do find myself picking them up
again and again
and can you help me understand what's
behind that
well you like anything that's yours
hmm
I mean if something
either something is true or it's not
true
what does it matter what you believe
what does it matter what your opinion is
of of what value is that aside from
trying to win some idiotic conversation
in some idiotic party
with a bunch of idiots talking idiocy
who cares what you believe
of what what what
two cents does it matter what your
opinion is and and once again because
everyone's conditioned they're going to
think that I I mean that you should be
mindful of others opinions
no I'm saying others opinions are stupid
too everyone's stupid
they're all stupid
either something is true
or it's not true
what you believe and what you opine
who cares
you can believe that the sun rises in
the north okay you're welcome to believe
that once again no evil
so what okay good for you
your opinion is that the Moon is purple
with green stripes great
good for you
what does that to do with reality
so then it just comes down to are you
more interested
in opinion and belief
or are you more interested in reality
and Truth
and there's no way that anyone is not
going to hear
the fact or the the notion that I'm
implying something
that I'm implying that you should be
interested in reality and Truth
and that's where my stuff differs I
don't apply anything
once again I don't care
it is simply I can't say a single thing
without there being a feeling that I'm
giving a hidden
I I'm leading you toward doing something
and and the reason that that happens is
because every single human being that
you speak to in your entire life
every single book that you read in your
entire life
absolutely is trying to lead you
somewhere
has a message for you
has something for you to get
has a take-home message
I don't have any message
I don't care if you look for truth we
care for belief I am just simply making
the absolute fact
no judgment no leading no implication
that
are if you are more interested in belief
and an opinion
then that's
what you will value and if you're more
interested in reality and truth that's
what you were that's what you will value
what what you will value and you
shouldn't be more interested in one or
the other you are whatever you are did
you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free